[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALYSSA GOODMAN: A lot of times when
we're talking about this PredictionX
effort in many different
venues, people say, oh, you
must be doing a lot about astrology,
because they know I'm an astronomer.
And I say no, actually I
know nothing about astrology.
But given how many people are very,
very interested in their own horoscope
today, and people have been
interested in that for generations,
we really thought it
was important to include
an expert astrologer, modern
astrologer in the course.
Not Isaac Newton who is
an expert old astrologer.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: When I think of astrology
I think it's man in astronomy.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mhm.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: You know, it's this kind
of how it might affect that person.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Yeah.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Those planets
around that person.
So when we look at a chart,
we are looking at the center
as if you were standing in the
center and the center is earth.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: OK?
So obviously, you know, the solar
system it would be heliocentric.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Right.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: But when we look at it
we're looking at from you on the earth
and what the planets are
symbolizing about you.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Is there any kind
of, like, physical connection
between the actual pole of
planets, for example, on a person
and what is forecast for them?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Everything's interconnect.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: And so that's my sense.
And that the movements do affect us.
And, um, I'm not sure what
it is, but I can tell you
after years of working
with people and charts,
it's uncanny what a chart reveals and
what the movements of planets or stars
can say about the person
or what's going to happen.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Well you
got me very curious now.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So I'm not sure
what the exact connection.
I know there's a connection.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: You know?
And from observation--
personal observation, you know.
Not just going on faith,
but that this is--
this is amazing, how, you know certain
things just come out over and over.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: So if I
understand, a lot of it
is like people have done this kind of
astrology for thousands of years and--
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Yep.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: --and I don't want
to put words in your mouth,
but that they just kind of learned more
and more about what kinds of things
you can predict from the
positions of planets.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Exactly.
I think a lot of this is in
some ways pattern recognition.
You know, when you have
certain combinations,
certain things tend to happen.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mhm.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: And it--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Now would the same
things happen for all people born
at the same time in the same place?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: No.
And that's what become--
that's where it's interesting.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mm, OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So I was just going to say
I--I don't believe that everything is
set in stone, you know.
I believe that there's
basic patterns and then
we have this free will to
move within these patterns.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So you'll see some people
with a certain configuration that's
very pronounced.
And you'll go, oh that person
is going to be very successful.
And they can do-- and maybe
that doesn't fully materialize.
And they had somebody else born
on that date at that place--
place is important too--
at that time, which is
very important, the time.
They may completely, you know, fulfill
that potential that we're reading--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Got it.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: --in the chart.
Astrology, because it's so
intricate, is about the relationships
between that planet and the sign, which
means the part of the sky it was in.
And how it's relating
to the other planets
and relating to earth
in a particular time
or particular day or particular place.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: What would you say is the
balance among your clients of people
who are very seriously looking to
you for advice about, you know,
business decisions and their
love life and whatever?
And-- and then other people
who are just kind of curious
and want to have the experience
of knowing their horoscope?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: In my-- in my practice
I would say I'm about 80-85% more
serious--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: --guidance, and maybe
15 to 20% were of the curious.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Got it.
Do you ever give people bad news?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Well I don't look
at anything as bad or good.
I look at it all as energy.
I'll tell people what to look for.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Yeah.
Um, I can tell when there's
going to be a lot of change.
OK?
I can tell when somebody's
going to go-- they're
going to need to let something big go.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mm hmm?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: OK?
So I can tell if there's something
going on maybe with Pluto working,
or Saturn aspecting Pluto, that they're
going to have to let a wave being go,
or there's some aspect of their
lifestyle that needs to change.
And my feeling is--
I'm kind of an optimist anyway.
But my feeling is-- is
that how I read astrology
is it's a way to understand
ourselves and our lives to help us.
So if there are the
more difficult or you're
saying bad or challenging aspects, I
ultimately see it from the big picture,
is trying to help us evolve.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Given that we're talking
about this being a long tradition
and that people didn't
know Pluto was even there
or that it was a planet or a dwarf
planet or whatever we want to call it--
KATHLEEN MEDINA: [LAUGHTER] Yeah.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Something
in the solar system.
Um, does it have new significance
because it exists, or?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Well I
understand your question.
So yeah we didn't read
the three outer planets,
right, until the last 150 years or so.
And so we wouldn't have looked at
that probably as aspecting Pluto.
This is your map of you.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
My universe.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: This is your universe.
This is giving me like a-- like a
Polaroid of what was in the sky.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: OK.
And so when you were born--
and we need the place, the date, but
we need the time to be really accurate.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Because, as you know,
the planets rotate in 24 hours.
So what's coming up over the horizon
is changing every two hours, roughly.
And that's called your ascendant.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mm hmm.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: This sets the
tone of the whole chart.
So what's rising in the sky is setting
the whole tone for you in terms
of how--
it's like the lens you see life through.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: That's called your
ascendant or rising sign.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Your rising sign is Libra.
And Libra is an air sign, so this
is more working with the intellect.
Libra is also about balance.
Libra is the scales, right?
So we have balance.
We have diplomacy.
It's very partnership oriented,
wanting to work together
with other people and teams.
So the houses are fields of influence.
In your case, 9th house
up here, top of the chart,
is representing higher education.
It's representing developing the mind.
It's represent foreign travel.
It's expansion of what's
possible in the world.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: So let me
back up for a second.
So this is about-- what--what we've
been saying is about sort of what kind
of person I might be, what
kind of personality I have.
And then does this kind
of horoscope get more
specific about events that are
going to happen in the future,
or people's tendencies?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: No.
We can-- we do both.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So this is your-- your map.
This is your star map.
This is-- this is giving me a blueprint.
This is your basic makeup, OK?
As an astrologer to look at it.
This is permanent for you.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mm hmm.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So then what
we do is we can look
at any particular time
in a person's life.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Now when
people come to see me
they're usually looking at what's
going on now, or maybe this next year,
or roughly at this time.
And so I do what's called a transit--
there's different things you can do.
I do a transits chart because
it's the most literal.
It's literally where the planets are
transiting, you know, in the orbit,
and how they may be
aspecting your birth chart.
So what we do is, when
we look at predictions
we're looking at what is that
nature and what may be aspecting it.
Maybe what is-- what is--
what's another word I can use for that?
Um, what is playing on it?
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So basically it's another
way of saying what's up for you.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
Yeah.
What's up for me?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: What's up for you?
One of the things that does jump
at me is that you've had Uran--
this is Uranus in Aries.
And it's been in Aries
since about March--
the planet Uranus has been in
Aries since I think March 2011.
So about seven years it's in there.
It has an 84 year orbit.
And it is working its way
through your seventh house.
What that tells me, without
knowing you, is this
could be very interesting,
good news for your love life.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Mm hmm.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: And because
Uranus in Aries is--
is wanting to-- Uranus is,
we call it, the awakener.
OK.
We call it the awakener
or the rejuvenator.
And it's an Aries.
It's like wanting new
energy, new action.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Sounds great.
I have a lot of decisions to make
about how many long trips to go on, um,
in the next six months or so.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: OK.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: And it could be anywhere
from about three to about six.
And six seems like kind of too much.
And is there any reason I should go
on every trip that I could go on?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So I can see that more
opportunities are coming to you.
I mean, no question.
And there's-- and travel
would be one of them.
However, you don't have to take
everything that comes along.
And-- and there is more of a
relaxing into some of this.
And you're-- here's one thing
I'm going to tell you for sure--
Is you need to trust
your intuition more.
And I'm not just saying
that as a blanket statement.
I'm saying that to you.
Because you have planets
lining up in such a way
that are suggesting that your
intuition is opening even more.
This could even indicate
like a spiritual opening.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Some sort of-- you know--
it could be through religious study,
it could be through an experience.
But it's a spiritual opening.
It's an opening in that consciousness.
This is indicating a lot of intuition.
You already are extremely intuitive
based on your birth chart.
This is tied to the travel question.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: OK.
What does that mean?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: So this is--
I'm not going to say taking it easier--
let me find the words for you--
ALYSSA GOODMAN: More time at the spa?
KATHLEEN MEDINA: Yes.
ALYSSA GOODMAN: Oh excellent.
KATHLEEN MEDINA: And you know--
you know, honestly, I don't--
I don't--
[MUSIC PLAYING]